[Musique]
ils étaient près de 12000 à s'être
donnés rendez vous ces immenses 20
octobre au stade paul julius bénard à
saint paul
comme chaque année le département
honorer nos gramounes en organisant la
journée départementale des personnes
âgées
chaque année la collectivité leur
consacre 100 millions d'euros pour leur
offrir les conditions du bien vieillir
et du mieux vivre
l'infection est au point mort merci à
nos travailleurs sociaux mais aciéries
services à toutes les associations qui
accompagnent les gramounes
la journée a débuté par la célébration
de la messe puis le public a pu profiter
des diversions d'informations sur
l'ensemble de leurs droits et de
dispositifs dont ils peuvent bénéficier
de nombreux bénévoles ont répondu
présents pour faire de cette journée une
réussite représente justement tout ce
qui est idéal et mon père c'est à dire
sur
les féculents les sucres lents les
matières à l'autre cinéma prononcé comme
avec les l'aménagement de la maison
fréchette à nancy des trucs sur comment
bien dormir sur un bâti de tabac
alors en fait on a souhaité être
bénévole pour
grazie à nos gramounes parce que c'est
important pour nous
j'aime la culture réunionnais c'est nos
origines quand on sait d'où on vient
dans ses rangs pas et c'est eux qui
portent la connaissance de la réunion
donc c'était dans ce but là que
personnellement je laissais et en plus
c'était pour changer un petit peu
d'habitude je travaille et que les
enfants et la jav avait travaillé avec
un public
le président du département un ensemble
désigne au mouret antoinette evans en
s'en tenir une journée festive et
conviviale qui permet de se retrouver de
vivre des moments de partage
les seniors premièrement le premier
seigneur chanter
moi bien
bien dit avec tout le monde voulait
donner la couronne
et tout groupe ou là mais c est pourquoi
ces zones est et le club les capucines
après le pique nique la troisième
jeunesse réunionnaise a laissé place à
la danse avec le traditionnel bal la
poussière
[Musique]